en el vídeo anterior veíamos cuántas
maneras distintas hay de sentar cinco
personas en tres sillas
así que si tenemos la silla número 1 la
silla número 2 y la silla número 3
analizábamos que la primera podríamos
escoger de 5 personas para la siguiente
tendríamos 4 personas y después solo nos
quedarán 3 personas para la última de
las sillas así que el número total de
permutaciones o sea todas las formas
distintas en las cuales podemos sentar a
tres personas en estas sillas tomando en
cuenta el orden será 5 por 4 por 3 otra
forma de pensar en esto sería poner en 5
esto sería igual a 5 por 4 por 3 por 2
por 1
todo esto dividido entre dos por uno y
esto es lo mismo que cinco factorial
entre 2 factorial y de dónde sale el 2
cuál es la relación del 2 con el 5 y el
3 bueno pues el 2 sale de la diferencia
del 5 menos 3 esto es igual a 5
factorial dividido entre 5 menos 3
factorial en general esta es la manera
en la que podemos calcular las
permutaciones de cinco objetos en tres
posiciones
y las permutaciones de cinco objetos
tomados en tres posiciones en la fórmula
general que ya lo habíamos visto en un
vídeo anterior voy a cambiar los colores
para que quede más clara es esta que
está aquí y es las permutaciones de n
objetos tomados en cada posiciones acá
tiene que ser menor o igual que en esto
es muy importante considerarlo y
entonces la fórmula general es la que
nos dice que esto es igual a n factorial
dividido entre n menos k factorial en la
verdad a mí por lo general me cuesta
mucho trabajo recordar la fórmula yo más
bien lo pienso que tengo 5 objetos de
los cuales escojo 1 para la primer
posición y entonces me restan cuatro de
los cuales entonces vuelvo a escoger uno
y me quedan tres es la manera en la que
yo trato de pensarlo tomó las posiciones
de las n que tengo posibles como en este
caso que 5 tomo 5 x 4 x 3
esto es genial si yo lo que estoy
pensando es en que tengo cinco personas
o sea escribamos las como abs de estas
son las cinco personas y esto está
genial si lo que queremos es contar las
permutaciones por ejemplo abc y contamos
a esta permutación distinta como la que
sería a se ve y está una permutación
distinta a la que obtendríamos al poner
de hace o probablemente la permutación
que obtenemos con bs a cuando hicimos
esto lo que nos importaba es donde están
sentados en el vídeo anterior estuvimos
contando justamente esto o sea lo que
nos importaba era si la persona
estaba sentada en la silla 1 o la
persona ve en la silla 2 y se
intercambiaban lugares lo tomábamos como
una cuenta nueva y qué pasaría si esto
no nos importara es decir que sólo
pensáramos en cuántas personas se pueden
sentar es cierto y si ahora contábamos
si las personas a b y c se pueden sentar
sin importar la posición ya sabes no nos
importaría quién ocupa cuál silla lo que
nos interesa es que las tres personas
estén sentadas este sería el subconjunto
de las personas que están sentadas y
ahora la pregunta ya no es cuántas son
las maneras en que la gente se puede
sentar la pregunta es cuántos
subconjuntos de tres elementos podemos
encontrar a partir de 5
y esto en esencia es lo que es una
combinación una combinación es una
permutación en la cual no nos importa el
orden y como lo calculamos bueno cuando
calculamos las permutaciones utilizando
esta fórmula contamos abc acb de ac/dc a
déjame ver si hay algunas otras
permutaciones si hay dos se ve y se ve a
contamos cada una de estas seis como
permutaciones distintas pero pensando en
combinaciones todas estas son la misma
combinación porque no nos importa el
orden bien así que para tres personas
con tres sillas habrá seis permutaciones
posibles si lo que estamos buscando son
las combinaciones basta con dividir el
número de personas que queremos sentar
entre el número de sillas que tenemos y
eso en esencia lo que hicimos aquí así
que de cuántas maneras puedes acomodar
tres personas entre sillas bueno esto
parece ser otro problema de
permutaciones
a la primera silla podré escoger de tres
personas para la segunda silla escoger
de dos personas y para la última silla
solo me queda una persona esto es igual
a tres factores que es igual a 6
esto es 3 factorial que es igual a 6
espero no estar confundiendo las cosas
lo que estoy intentando decir cuando
estamos haciendo permutaciones lo que
estamos contando es el orden en que las
personas pueden acomodarse y lo que
estoy diciendo ahora es que las formas
de acomodarse va a ser el número de
lugares factorial porque si tenemos tres
personas en tres lugares o tenemos
cuatro personas en cuatro lugares el
primer lugar lo podrá ocupar cualquiera
de las cuatro personas el segundo lugar
cualquiera de las tres personas
restantes el segundo lugar de las dos
personas y el último una persona el
número del lugar es factorial es el
número de permutaciones que estamos
contando y para calcular las
combinaciones ahora lo que tenemos que
pensar es por ejemplo si tenemos cinco
personas y cuántos grupos de tres se
pueden sentar esta vez no nos interesa
contar el orden o por ejemplo contar
como en estos seis veces las mismas tres
personas y esto lo vamos a calcular como
las permutaciones de cinco lugares
tomados en tres y esto lo voy a dividir
entre las formas en que las 3
se pueden acomodar de diferentes maneras
que es 3 factorial
más adelante haré más ejemplos para que
quede más claro
así que diremos que cuántas son las
maneras de escoger n elementos o las
combinaciones de n elementos
en subconjuntos de elementos r será
menor o igual que n
esto será igual al número de
permutaciones que podemos hacer con n
elementos tomados de reposiciones
/ / r factorial porque lo vamos a
dividir entre el número de posibilidades
de acomodar estos r elementos y ahora si
tomamos la fórmula de aquí arriba bueno
aquí arriba era acá abajo es r esto va a
ser igual
a n factorial dividido entre n - r
factorial y todo dividido entre r
factorial
así que ahora no voy a escribir aquí
arriba para que quede más claro entonces
las combinaciones de n tomadas en er
otra forma de escribirlo es decir las
combinaciones de n tomadas en er y este
es el teorema del binomio y tenemos
otras series de vídeos acerca de este
tema en especial los que tienen que ver
con expansiones de polinomios a
potencias esto es igual a n factorial
que está dividido por r factorial que
multiplica a n
- r factorial puedes memorizar esto a
veces es útil porque no lo preguntan en
los exámenes pero una forma de pensarlo
es que en efecto real que está dividido
entre n
factorial esas son las permutaciones
esto sería como tomar los primeros r
factores de n los más grandes de n
factorial
y para obtener las combinaciones pues lo
dividimos entre todas las posibilidades
de sentar a estas personas así que en
esta situación si quisiéramos calcular
cuáles son las combinaciones para tres
personas de este grupo de cinco personas
o cinco letras como le quieras decir
entonces será cinco factorial que está
dividido entre tres factorial por cinco
menos tres factorial
y esto es 5 por 3 por 2 por 1
dividido entre 3 factorial que 6 que
está x 2 por 1 que eso es 2 factorial y
estos que están multiplicando el 2 por 1
se cancelan pues están en el numerador y
en el denominador así que tenemos 5 por
3 2 y del 4 no es 5 por 4 por 3 que es
el número de las permutaciones y luego
dividido entre 6 porque 6 fueron las
permutaciones que obtuvimos y entonces
tenemos 5 por 4 por 3 dividido entre 6
que esto es igual a 5 por 12 dividido
entre 6 que esto es igual a 5 por 2 que
esto es igual a 10 10 combinaciones de
tres tomados de 5 nos veremos pronto